can we talk about the difference in
creating a fascinating protagonist for
film versus television or maybe it's the
same for film I think it's gonna be
affected by that closed ending because
there arc is going to arc over the
course of this 90 to 120 minute film or
90 two hundred and ten page screenplay
and then it's going to end basically and
that's where we're gonna leave the
character whereas a TV protagonist they
have to be able to go through various
arcs over the course of years you know
it may be on for ten seasons so there
needs to be the potential for that kind
of growth now you don't need to know
what's going to happen to this character
for ten seasons but it would be good to
know the basics of what will happen like
in the first two or three seasons for
example any examples of characters well
if you give your protagonist a lot of
emotional baggage then there's gonna be
a lot to unpack you know over time
something like carry from homeland she's
bipolar and she is reckless in her
behavior and she starts an affair with
this guy that she's supposed to be
tracking that's a potential terrorist in
season one so she's kind of a mess and
so there's definitely gonna be drama
with her going forward or or Don Draper
from Mad Men he has the secret
personality from the past and he has the
secret that he's keeping who what is his
true identity
that's always a risk to come out to
destroy him so if you keep some kind of
element there some kind of Achilles heel
always there and ready to destroy them
then you're gonna get a lot of seasons
of material out of that hero let's talk
about for a feature film because you
said there's that that closure so what
what makes can you give any examples of
an interesting protagonist could be
current film could be yeah a classic
example of a great character arc would
be Indiana Jones and Raiders of the Lost
star
you know that first Indiana Jones film
his Ark is to accept the supernatural he
doesn't believe in anything supernatural
or spiritual he doesn't believe in God
okay so when he gets this mission to
find the Ark of the Covenant he does he
just thinks it's a relic you know he
doesn't think that it's actually
something that could have any kind of
power
his final fruition of the Ark is when he
respects let's say God's power and the
power of the Ark and he shuts his eyes
and he tells Marion to shut her eyes
once the Ark has been open and the power
of the ark kills all the Nazis but does
not hurt him and Marion because they've
respected God and not looked at the face
of God so it's not just him in a fight
you know you would think it's an action
movie non-stop action it would be him
fighting the head Nazi it's not at all
and that's what makes it such an
interesting choice for the character and
to close the film it's him respecting
the spiritual world
you